peu
[Musique]
oooh
oh
[Musique]
à
bon sang mais dame bon sens
mesdemoiselles bonsoir messieurs
j'espère que vous allez tous bien penser
agir à dachau que nous arrivons bien en
nous voyant chaque soir le truc
appartenant monsieur durand de la
rochelle la clé du mystère vaut 600
francs aujourd'hui est un tout nouveau
truc 300 francs le pari du bas mesdames
messieurs bonsoir votre nom notre
premier candidat albert du verger fleuri
candidate numéro 2 pour nous et c'est en
1910 candidat numéro 3 scherrer seror de
châtillon sous bagneux candidate numéro
quatre un impact d'avion eh bien madame
pas d'avion j'ai d'abord vous faire une
grosse bise ainsi que gérard parce que
vous êtes la 500e candidate de notre
émission alors en vous a plu du bien
fort son 100e oui je vous donne même si
vous ne gagnez pas le livre il ya un
truc candidate numéro 5 qui êtes suisse
a de clamart et candidat numéro 6
laurent de pierrefitte
nous regardons ensemble la clé du
mystère appartenant à monsieur durand de
la rochelle 600 francs lucien durand et
représentant à la rochelle nous a
proposé un truc très étrange une clé
tient tout seul sur une surface par cole
pas de colle mais encore en fait vous
savez monsieur majak il ya un truc et
c'est à vous de le trouver
c'est à vous de les trouver monsieur
diverger il y a pas de talent mais y at
il autre chose que de la colle à la même
s'il faudrait quand même que vous me
parliez précisément autre chose que de
la can see a pas de calais toujours
autre chose en transe et quelconque
évidemment autres il ya autre chose que
la clé jeudi à écouter monsieur poser
moins de questions précises la pâte à
modeler ah non non non non ce serait une
forme de colle
non non non candidate numéro tva on ne
voyait pas du tout nous passons tout de
suite à notre troisième candidat
monsieur seror bien le mur et en bois le
mur il ya une chance et un décor et nous
avons utilisé ce décor monsieur durand
m'a expliqué qu'il peut
or cela sur n'importe quel mur mme mais
enfin pour l'instant basons nos sources
le fait que ce décor et du bois
recouvert d'une peinture mais monsieur
durand l'a fait devant moi dans les murs
d'antenne 2 en fait dans les couloirs
d'antenne 2 où les murs était en plâtre
sans doute et puis recouvrir de peinture
également bien et il y a quelque chose
sur ce mur un produit qu'on mettra à
l'avant ce qui permet chose je vais
retenir
oui vous pensez à quoi monsieur à du
papier adhésif ah non non si c'était dur
grandi ce serait une forme de cole
monsieur quand monsieur durand vous dit
il n'y a pas de colle ce serait quand
même un petit peu gros monsieur de
servir de ruban adhésif ce n'est pas
cela madame pas que notre 500e candidate
et ennuyant la clé en mouillant la clé
au malheureux mais moi j'aurais peur
quand ça sèche
1 ça pourrait être une forme de cône
lomé en séchant non ça tomberait
mademoiselle suissa je voudrais savoir
si on frottant la clé contre la manche
comme ceux ci après la clé tiendrait
compte revenir enfin temps quand on la
mange mais vous l'essayez venez avec moi
ce serait étonnant lenval
il faut dire tout de suite ce n'est pas
la solution de monsieur durand mais il
faut essayer alors frotté bien à la clé
contre la mienne aussi voulait contre la
mienne non fallait montrer bien nos amis
ce que vous faites c'est pas de la laine
vous ainsi c'est très beau jeu manger
chez moi aussi alors j'étais d'abord la
face à fait rien ça marche avec les
pièces de monnaie des bidons ça nous
fera un nouveau truc c'est dommage que
vous l'ayez dit mais ce n'est pas cela
candidat numéro 6 monsieur laurent est
ce qu'on appliquerait pas plutôt la
pièce une fois que la peinture vient
d'être fait
la peinture toute fraîche ah non
monsieur alors là à la peinture fait oui
un tour qui ne sera là qu'avec la
peinture fraîche
vous savez notre décor je ne pense pas
qu'il soit frais
comment ça marche parce que monsieur
durand l'a fait regarder j'applique ma
main pour la somme à main et de couleur
normale je la pique sur le bleu si ma
main et bleu ah non monsieur vous n'avez
pas gagné
mais pas de la peinture fraîche et bien
la clé du mystère reste un mystère
pas pour monsieur durand mais pour nous
et pour une prochaine émission elle
vaudra 900 francs un tout nouveau truc
300 francs le baril du bar pour ce pari
de bar il faut un verre un sous bocks
une cigarette est une pièce d'un franc
d'abord il faut réaliser un équilibre la
celle sous bocks sur le verge qui l
inverse ce qu'on fait d'habitude et la
cigarette sur le soul rock et finalement
la pièce d'un franc en eau en équilibre
maintenant le problème est le suivant
comment faire tomber la pièce de monnaie
à l'intérieur du verre sans toucher à
quoi que ce soit à vous de trouver le
truc
messieurs du verger étant donné qu'on ne
peut pas y toucher je pense que il faut
souffler dessus
ah oui comment monsieur soufflé sur le
quartier mais venez venez essayer
monsieur car là c'est une question très
précise vais peut-être raison en effet
je suis obligé de reconnaître qu'un
souffle monsieur peut-être une partie de
la solution mais il faut savoir comment
sous le carton en souffrance mais
essayez monsieur je vous en prie
attendez attendez pas ce que ça sera
plus facile pour vous comme cela au bord
en est le plus difficile voyez vous
c'est d'arriver à faire tenir le tout
vous aviez déjà vu ce genre de chose
monsieur dit pas du tout c'est la
première fois
monsieur vous êtes perspicace allez-y à
écouter monsieur vous savez ce que vous
allez faire mais nous sommes entre nous
voir vous allez vous mettre au bord me
suis un peu plus accroupi car c'est la
solution venait par là monsieur vous
allez essayer comme cela on va pousser
le micro de la fin notre cameraman
ne vois tu bien vous allez essayer au
bord mettez vous bien la copie monsieur
n'ayez pas peur vous savez on est là
pour s'amuser alors attendez le plus
difficile pour moi c'est de placer la
pièce mais parce que je suis très
nerveux même si je n'ai pas l'air
allez-y moi je voudrais quand même
savoir monsieur ça me paraît pas
pensable canton tout de suite ce genre
de choses qui rendent très près celle de
l'instant vous avez dit qu'il fallait
absolument pas y toucher
je suppose je ne voyais que ça que cette
solution de souffler dessus souffler et
bien monsieur si ça vous paraissait
évident je ne pense pas que ça le soit
beaucoup de téléspectateurs à moi ça
n'était pas voix s'il ya un truc est
venu qu'il vous fait la bise parce que
c'était quand même une émission vous
avez gagné 300 francs monsieur diverger
bravo et bien tant pis je suis désolé
pour nos cinq autres candidats
mais la clé du mystère 900 francs pour
une prochaine émission est un tout
nouveau truc la loi magnétique 300
francs on les regarde ensemble
[Musique]
lucien durand et représentant à la
rochelle nous a proposé un truc très
étrange une clé tient tout seul sur une
surface par cole pas de col mènent
encore en fait vous savez monsieur majak
il ya un truc et c'est à vous de le
trouver aujourd'hui un truc avec des
noirs elles sont posées dans une
assiette et après les avoir remué un
petit moment on essaie un phénomène
magnétique et un an
je suis de monter très doucement les
mains et toutes les noix remonte à celle
ci est mauvaise mais deux sont bonnes
etienne contre les doigts
mystérieusement
mais là aussi il ya un truc lequel
[Musique]